[Music]
do you guys hear
on the internet that annabelle escaped
annabelle the doll
i thought that was a joke wait what
we're talking about like the actual
annabelle the doll from the movie
okay so you know how there is a doll
that is like a haunted doll
and they made movies around this doll so
this is it's based on a natural adult
based on an actual doll she's a raggedy
handle
and she's possessed by this little girl
named annabelle higgins
and so she has been
locked up at the warren museum so
warren's they were the ones that were
investigating paranormal activity and if
you guys saw emilyville
oh are they the couple yeah the couple
and then also conjuring
and annabelle that's who the warrens are
they the trilogy
yeah is it i think they're all linked
yeah they are linked but i don't know if
it's a trilogy
they're literally the stupidest couple
in the world you go in the house
if your [ __ ] pantry door is flapping
around you move out right yeah those
fools like i can see ourselves slightly
down here
like let's build a museum here really
i'm like yeah i'm like why the [ __ ]
would you do that
wait what do you mean i mean it's a
movie because they they was the movies
based on real life
like you go you walk up the stairs and
all the pictures are like this on the
wall
that's their profession they dedicated
themselves to doing that they study it
did they end up dying are they alive
they're not alive
oh i don't know how they passed but are
they just old
i think they were probably just older
they got to meet the things they were
studying
hopefully hopefully they didn't oh they
became the things that they studied oh
no okay so that's so funny this is house
it's lovely it's haunted i i want it
honey this is i've been looking for this
all my life
yeah there's people that like love us
[ __ ] honey did you see the floating bed
in the bedroom i know
have you ever bought something and been
[ __ ] though where you're like oh no it
went down a little bit in my investment
i'm just gonna stay here
oh yeah you know what i mean maybe some
[ __ ] like that true
yeah so recently it went viral that
annabelle the doll had escaped and there
were oh [ __ ] ton of memes on the
internet they were just like what the
[ __ ]
2020 literally cannot get anywhere and
why was she so sexy
wait what are you talking about do we
see the same doll
did your anna ball look like this this
this is the annabelle dolly
they're like she's breaking quarantine
and she's like in a bikini
at the beach and i was like why is she
sexy underneath those clothes and [ __ ]
yeah that's how raggy ants look like no
no no this is the movie
one this is the real life one oh okay
that's
that's a lot better one i was like why
would anyone even make the other doll
for kids
but so they just did annabelle replace
raggedy anne in there and ran out run
away
no so positively do not open positively
oh or oh negatively huh so somebody just
stole it dude here's what happened there
has to be cameras
or it didn't happen but don't you have
to open the case to change that light
bulb on top
that's shining oh yeah she could escape
that way huh the light bulb literally on
top of the the display case
yeah so what ended up really happening
here is that annabelle did not escape
she's still in her in her little prison
obviously she's an inanimate object um
but the the reason why that rumor spread
was because
okay so annabelle wallace who is an
actress who played
mia in the movie annabelle so this chick
yeah her name is annabelle i don't
remember her in the movie she also was
in the movie annabelle
and so she was being interviewed for a
different movie that she's doing
and during that interview she had
mentioned how
uh like she was talking about what it
was like to work with tom cruise and the
mummy and then she also talked about
running and and then there was also a
video of some of the escape scenes from
the mummy since they were talking about
it
so tom cruise runs a lot in all the
movies he runs really [ __ ] fast he
runs a lot
yeah he does run a lot yeah they're
probably talking about that i bet well
they were talking about her running
so um i'll get paid to run anyway so
then what ended up happening is
that hollywood reporter article uh
translated into chinese and because of
the mistranslation
people in china thought that when they
said annabelle escaped
they thought they met the doll annabelle
because of the fact that she was in the
movie why are they so nosy over there
you tell us you tell us dear people
i don't know anything about the chinese
chinese i'm chinese american
were they trying to call and warn people
like no so then that's when
hey did you guys know this like based on
their track record probably not oh i see
okay you got it yeah so then that's when
it just
started spreading like wildfire that
annabelle the doll escaped
and it's pretty much not true so it came
from chinese news yes
so chinese people were like oh my god
did you know the annabelle just ran away
like a [ __ ] what what are
americans doing
americans did you know that [ __ ] and
then the americans were like we didn't
know that
they're like just take care of the
goddamn virus [ __ ]
will you take care of your dog then okay
how are you gonna let a dog like that go
outside and [ __ ] everybody up
yeah yeah so what ended up happening
here so the
the person that's in charge of the
warren occult warren's occult museum
a cult museum that's what it's called
museum there in connecticut yeah in
connecticut
how big is do you know how big it is i
think it's pretty small house i don't
know
but in the pictures i've seen yeah it
looks like it's really small and so
the person who has inherited all of
those things is
the warren's son-in-law so this
son-in-law his name is tony
he's the one that's trying to find a new
home because they actually had to shut
down the museum for
zoning purposes like zoning reasons um
no cursed things here
no haunted [ __ ] about if i'm the mayor
of connecticut i'm like that house is
condemned i'm burning that [ __ ]
it's full of curses
sensible right yeah because uh
they they have an entire museum because
they would collect items from all their
investigations why would they
why that's like let me have a collection
of viruses
like disperse that [ __ ] all over
the world yeah i'm with you
just leave some curses here some curses
there
but they could protect the world from it
so like they were housing
housing all these like yeah but an evil
[ __ ] walks in and then they
steal annabelle
and then i don't know well they just
might have bad ideas right like
what if the museum curator is like a
evil [ __ ] and they're like i'm
going to use
it sounds like it sounds like you're
talking about like the storage of mass
destruction weapons and they're like
if they take the animal doll they could
use it for some crazy [ __ ]
they could they could hold up a bank
with this dog they know how to unlock it
yeah you don't know worse than holding
up a bank that shit's not
sound crazy nelson you sound crazy you
can harness the power
the other haunted doll that was really
famous based
like that's in real life that also made
movies which is chucky
is the robert doll have you guys heard
of that guy what does it look like
chuckie wasn't even that scary though
i kicked that was based off of a real
thing too yeah the robert dog
chuckie was funny i thought you see what
it looks like does he have a scar in his
face too as a kid
oh yeah i watched chucky as a kid and
scared of [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
the same i remember me but then i
watched it again as an adult and i was
like this is dumb
it's really good it's kind of i still
haven't seen it as an adult because i
was [ __ ] terrified when i was a child
this is robert oh [ __ ] that dude oh why
does he
look like that wait wait wait wait wait
but that dog is cute as [ __ ] though dude
why was that made he looks like a crash
doesn't though
he's probably made in like the [ __ ]
20s yeah it looks ancient
it's like an egyptian pharaoh kind of
thing it does it's so weird like it's
mummified yeah
and all that yeah i don't know it says
that it was once
uh once owned by key west florida
painter and author
i want to go to shitty museums i love
shitty little museums like those
roadstop
museums all that what's the shittiest
one you visited it was on a road trip
in uh new mexico i believe
but it was the only [ __ ] gas station
stop
in like miles gas station and museum
yeah
nice and a trailer park and it's so
like hyped up that they bought like 20
or more uh billboards just to
just deleting that's like yeah yeah on
both sides too what's it called
it's like come see the thing oh i've
seen the thing it's the thing right
you're like
that's right so you're just like what is
this [ __ ] thing i would go and then
you go in and they have a gift shop
you could get like new mexican things or
like you know kind of
indian looking things not old mexicans
new mexican things yeah yeah
it's not real mexican either it's they
got like highlighter ponchos and like
different
neon colored yeah cactus shaped chips
yeah
all kinds of weird [ __ ] right and then
so you go through this
it's like this weird collectible antique
music i mean what the thing is
what's the thing what the thing is he's
building up the suspect so you gotta go
through
buying the billboards there's there's
like there's there's there's things that
they collected
old telephones there's like half of a
car
there's like things that you're just
which way this one half or something
there you go they they chopped the car
like down the middle
yeah and then they just parked it there
and it's like a they have like a [ __ ]
carriage
they have like old antique furniture
right you keep so it's a junkyard
that's well that's that's nicely
displayed right yeah
it's like a collection of beautifully
displayed things that's shaped into you
we have to pass their homes like their
trailer park to go through it right
and then at the very end they hype this
up they're like it's the thing right
and then you look and it's kind of like
this clear casket thing
and it looks like some kind of fake
mummified creature
like a like a humanoid kind of thing but
it's so whack like
like you look at it you're just like
what the [ __ ] dude and they're like
right
i swear i think i spent like three bucks
for that [ __ ] show
what you just described is how my mother
feels because she's a hoarder
and when you're going through her house
every time you're like mom you've had we
were throwing this away
she's like no that's the thing i i no i
need that one
and so no matter what you pick up it's
the thing then your mom should have just
had a display case
and put all of her hoarding things like
there but it was it was nicely displayed
like it was like
they did yeah they're probably horrible
they just collected all these
weird antiques and [ __ ] yeah it was
weird
and then uh we heard like some kind of
trailer
like ruckus in the trailer park so we're
just like oh [ __ ] now that's even
scarier than the thing so we ran back
into the store have you ever been to
meteor crater
no oh that sounds cool where is that one
it's in arizona i think
was that where they left joe dirk uh
maybe maybe close them in grand canyon
oh okay this is basically like it's like
gotta come to meteor crater
and then it's like all this cool stuff
and they have like like a picture of a
comet like on
like coming to earth a meteor coming to
earth and [ __ ] but when you get there
it's just a big hole
yeah and you're like yeah i'll have like
cool crevices i don't know man or is it
like a smooth i'm not a whole expert i
just was like
damn oh poor nicki was in like a big
hole
or was it just a hole it was a pretty
big hole was it epic
looking probably was it like the size of
this office hole no no it's jug it's a
gigantic crater like the rolls bowl side
selling it though steve
the reason why it's so wild is because
the meteor was like this big
and it created a hole that big yeah so
you're just like imagine
something this small made a big [ __ ]
hole
you should wear yourself yes you read my
mind was it still there the meteor
well the [ __ ] no it's it's it's gone
it's gone it's like smithereens
even better if they left it there you
could see that would have been sick yeah
or at least you would need binoculars if
it's if it was there you need to [ __ ]
look at it like this
i feel like it explodes if it hits the
ground that hard oh it's just
disintegrated immediately
that's that's probably that's why it
creates that impact and all the [ __ ]
fallout that they were selling too in
the gift shop they were selling the
fallout they're selling all the [ __ ]
rocks and [ __ ]
meteor dust yeah or like this one has
like this one got a little poof from the
meteor impact
so you're like okay you will buy those
things i have a little piece of the
berlin wall
my mom gave it to me i don't know i get
it she was there that's cool though
i like shitty museums though that's my
[ __ ] [ __ ] these big ass
multi-million billion dollar ones it's
all about the shitty ones you know the
shitty ones are great
they should just display it this is a
shitty one come see it come to our
shitty museum
[Music]
you